[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
raconte moi quand tu étais au pays de
jeunes à dire par bérénice me demandais
quelque chose je ne pouvais pas le lui
refuser il fait beau on n'a pas fait
tout ils sont bien sûr notre petit ben
amer nous sommes tranquilles bien
tranquille à borny tuner vol à pain oui
on ne te plaît regardons tout distrait
du buddh
c'est enfin c'est toi qui me les hummer
mois
mont louis debré bonne humeur j'en fais
tout pour te distraire votre main lors
d'un vote au promène parlons-en de thé
promenade nous venons ici nous asseyons
sur ce banc tu dois voir des deux bouts
ni à 6 ni debout je me promenais là
alors au nom non je veux me promener en
va-t-il en voiture manon l'avons pas de
voiture il aya kanno bill thies lui
bully olayan comme on dit les torrents
yaka et qui a bien trop tard de lui
poser là lui emprunter on veut pas pour
du grand encore enfin c'est sa gamme
audi je peux pas y emprunter n'en
parlons plus c'est la dernière fois que
je me promène avec toi
atypique et de rémy te parle pas
sérieusement qui dit à thierry this je
crois que tu présentais tu veux vraiment
te promener dans la gata mobile du grand
yaka committee sa mère d'ali baba
je vais voir je vais voir si je peux
avoir la niaque amende il attends moi
ici je vais parler à montre qu'à mon cas
bonjour mon camp je te dérange au chef
du parti tu cherchais des ports voilà
mon cas j'ai besoin un peu le besoin de
rayak à mobile vous vous trouvez la
claque qu'ils
stitch tu parles sirius pas c'est une
question de vie ou de mort alors alors
dans ce cas là je par l'institut homo kg
près tomberait en vie merci ma vie mais
attention pour un quart d'heure
seulement qui touche un quart d'heure et
prom imoca pour un tardin
payet des limites mon cas est d'accord
nous avons là y'a qu'à mobile pour un
cadre de vie via calavi c'est ici le
garage qu'elle est belle installe toi et
ton père dit un quart d'heure c'est du
passé ne va pas trop vite si tu veux
voir le paysage est très facile à
conduire
entièrement automatique de mélo guidage
radar way you lie à la victime un oui
oui un peu d'impatience
je comprends pas plus parce de bienvenue
le compact à la tis nous partons fo doit
être l'allumage qui va mal je vais voir
sans doute peu de choses mais faut le
trouver quoi est ce tout petit eu le
temps passe je me demande si c'est pas
faux contact dans le circuit électrique
sa loi avec l'arrivée d'air elle étouffé
ladesou psychiatres ou des labels notant
patiente pas de l'approuver elle est
tout ce que j'ai fait après dans elle va
démarrer
dépêchons-nous titus du talent voilà à
tourner
cette médaille est en direct sur place
je vous ai décrit sa nouvelle est de
retour le quart d'heure et cervidés
elle n'aime pas encore partir mon parti
mais voyons il touche
que s'est il passé on m'en parle à la
demande ils ne meurent pas des mauvais
en n'étant pas ça dépend titus ça dépend
le frein tu as oublié de le déchirer les
regardent en se déportant le point
croyez moi les yeux en amande il est
aussi capricieux que les souris et après
après et du nom du doigt
[Musique]